IT MOMENTARILY.
NOW TAKES ON THE
REGULAR SEASON.
D THEM BOTH.
INTO OVERTIME IN
TORONTO IT TO GO CALLED A
THEY'RE LOVING IT.
I AM SPEECHLESS. THE
SHOT, BUT NOT IN
BRUNSON.
DOWN THE
STRETCH.
SHAQ IN THE STUDIO IS LOVING  S
DOUBLE AT LUKA.
JAZZ DOING SECONDS.FOULS.
DONCIC TRYING TO FIND HIM.
HE FRONT BY ONE. BOUNCE TO HAVE
OUTSIDE, THE JUMPE
AND THAT'S STYLE
>> Stan: WOULD I THI SPACE.
>> Brian: BOSTON LEADS. WILLIAM
ANTETOKOUNMPO GIVES HIM SOME AP.
MARCUS SMART GOES TO THE
KNOCKS
BUCKET.
AS BROWN MISSES A TOUGH ONE
GOING TO HIS LEFT.
BACK IN TO HORFORD'S SCREEN.
I GO RIGHT BACK TO WON'T GO DOW
CURRY
LOONEY, LAY-UP.
DRAYMOND
GREEN, AND THAT'S A GUTSY ALL.
THEAMS BOTH BOUNCE BACK
AFTER TOUGH